[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Howie Long the Hall of
Famer I think you retired at 33 Howie
does that sound right uh I played in the
Pro Bowl 34 so yeah the season was 33.
but but you know do you do you have a
day where you go hey this is this is the
day I make my decision like did you have
a Moment of clarity where you go okay
that's it I'm gonna retire
well my problem was
in terms of family I have three sons
Chris was eight at the time uh
and
with football you're just particularly
at that point where I played 13 years
and not a dollar of my money was
guaranteed uh when you start getting up
towards double digits in surgeries you
know that's one part of the equation the
other part of the equation is Chris is
eight years old and I'm not there for
Burger day I'm not there for you know
bad day uh and I seriously wanted to
change that given my background I wanted
my uh my father-son relationship with my
three boys to be to be different and you
know I never regretted I had the
opportunity to coach little league
baseball for eight years High School
football for eight years uh watched them
all kind of go on their way to college
and like you said you know your
situation was kind of similar where you
know wait a second what are we doing
here this is going to be over you know
before you know it and I'm glad I did I
really am
and you know I I don't want anybody to
retire if you want to play continue to
play you know unless you uh your body
says you can't play any longer but
what do you think is that the core of
this with Brady he wants to win
championships it's all about
championships I don't know if you do
inventory with the Buccaneers and say I
don't know who's coming back can we
still win another championship then you
start to factor in with family I think
Giselle has been campaigning behind the
scenes for a while to have Tom retire
here so how do you think this plays out
well I I think there are there are
players who who are consumed and then
there's Tom uh Tom's at another level
and and that's not just you know August
through January that's the off season
and the kind of trick to it is and you
know you have to pay the piper because
the older you get the more you have to
do in the off season
and I think you know Tom Mick made a
good point that yeah you do have time
off in the off season as a football
player but for that six months seven
months you're you're checked out uh
whether you've been in or not because
you know it's it's next week it's on to
the next week you know forget about last
week and it's on to the next day and you
know in those days Wednesday Thursday
practices were you know full go live
goal line live inside run Live pass Rush
live team period now they're in hats and
you know physically I think players are
are capable playing longer because
they're being taken care of them
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if he walks
away but I think that could be in part
to maybe Tampa is not going to be one of
the elite teams next year given they got
to resign some people salary cap issues
all of those things
um I'm wondering if the NFL addresses
over time in the off season usually
takes you know a moment where we go I'm
upset with overtime and then we calm
down but would you would you want the
NFL to reconsider what overtime is maybe
in the playoffs not necessarily regular
season
yeah I I you know I I certainly you know
being at the game you know I with a son
on Kansas City I I'm I'm happy that you
know uh Kansas City gets the ball drives
down the field of scores a touchdown
that's that's great
but the opposite happens to them a few
years ago versus New England Andy Reid
brought it up and uh it was not it
didn't draw much of any support
um I think this one because of this kind
of game where
you know it's it's not the Patriots in
Atlanta where the Patriots are down 28-3
this was Ali Frazier 15 rounds these two
guys you know just when you think wow he
can't respond to that you know Mahomes
does or or Alan does the next series and
it was a Showcase of
what I think is uh you know we always
wonder where the when's the next
generation of quarterbacks coming and
you know with us it was Mourinho and
Elway and Jim Kelly and Warren Moon and
you know uh Steve Young and all that and
we just I think we're throwing the ball
more now than ever uh and I think the
interesting thing about both guys came
from not big programs Josh Allen was a
guy who you know struggled to get
scholarship offers ends up going to
Wyoming the knock on him was he he was
inaccurate
um and it's an interesting kind of
exercise is
how many teams would trade for Patrick
Mahomes
I I don't think Buffalo is on that list
how many teams would trade for Josh
Allen I don't think Kansas City's on
that list I think they're both happy
with their quarterback it's just it's
nuance and it's you know play here a
play there in a game like that zero
turnovers
four penalties it was just a great great
game and it was emotionally exhausting
just sitting in the stands
so how do you change overtime
well I think you have I I think you have
to say both teams have an opportunity to
possess the ball uh you know I I think
there are those who say well wait a
second okay
you you can't sit against the ball if if
you don't want the game to end then you
know force them to kick a field goal and
Josh Allen have an opportunity to drive
down the field score touchdown I I I
certainly see where and it's certainly
something that's been brought up
you know by a number of people just in
passing whether it's a hotel or you know
in traveling uh I think people want to
see both teams get the ball and I think
it's something Andy brought up and Andy
was happy that uh it got poo poo you
know a few years ago talking to Howie
Long the Hall of Famer and fox will have
San Francisco against the Rams
you know people try to say all the right
things about Jimmy Garoppolo Howie you
know that that he he all he does is win
I really it's about he does it he
doesn't lose I don't think he wins it's
just he he doesn't lose you're asking
him not to lose it feels like
I think Terry had one of those Yogi
Bears
years ago and I and I he and I talked
about it last week you can lose with me
but you can't win without me and you
know Jimmy is he's under so much fire
all the time he's got the thumb he's got
the shoulder he's beat up
um
you just take the Green Bay for example
you know they were under a lot of
pressure uh things weren't working out
it looks like any throw outside the
numbers is is a Herculean task for him
uh but at the end of the game
when it counted and it was the same
thing with the ram game uh he just comes
through and you know is is he the guy
that
is he the guy that you signed to a you
know 130 million dollar deal I'm not
sure that's going to be the case I think
there'll be a market for Jimmy and I
think they have an interesting decision
to make whether the Young quarterback is
ready and and uh Jimmy certainly is well
liked by the team and and you know as
evidenced by the Kittle comments and uh
comments from a number of teammates they
believe in him they think they can win
with him that's all that's important and
Dan it really doesn't matter what you
think or I think or anyone outside the
building thinks they like Jimmy
Garoppolo the team does you all in on
the Rams
you know I I give this San Francisco
teams tough uh they really really are
they're beat up I mean it seemed like
every other place somebody was hobbling
off the field whether it was demo
Samuels Williams uh you know they've
they've got a number of guys that are
banged up and you're gonna remember all
the teams that are left or have played
the Full Slate of games because the two
number one seeds are are now down so
we're on in on in Uncharted Territory
coming up here real soon
um if they can run the ball effectively
which you know listen
three of the four coaches that were left
in the final four uh you look at the
floor you look at Shanahan you look at
McVay they all coach and Washington they
all ran the same system or variations of
it and I think these two are contrasting
Styles and what they want to do uh I
think the last time the Rams had a first
round pick it was you know Barack Obama
was in office I mean they just do it
differently they do it more like the
Yankees or the Lakers
um now they have to kind of follow
through on a new state five billion
dollar Stadium I I think ownership made
it very clear that they wanted to play
in this game so there's a lot riding on
this game for the Rams
I think your Raiders go Jim Harbaugh
Josh McDaniels other
I have no idea I I really don't
um are you involved I thought I thought
Rich Versace did a great job yeah I
really did I thought he did himself a
real solid uh with the way he performed
you think about the chaotic situation
there with you know the Gruden departure
uh the rugs you know tragedy uh those
are things that really really
you know can rock a football team and
they had a bit of a dip there for three
four games and you know he kind of
brought him out of it you know I I think
the comparison would be
um John Harbaugh coming from
Philadelphia as a special teams coach to
to the Ravens and you know that special
teams coach like the strength coach he
interfaces with every single guy on the
team and uh I think they liked him they
feared him sufficiently uh but you know
Mark's got to make that decision
he's interviewing a lot of people I
think they're being very thorough
are you in a wine cellar like what's
what's the rock what's the right uh I'm
in Arizona this is our dining room uh
it's the only quiet spot I could find
where the dog wouldn't bark or you know
that's your dining room that you've got
it looks like a castle wall behind you
it looks Game of Thrones right right no
it it does I I imagine it does but it's
really the quietest spot in the house
I'm sorry you know I got Seaton driving
through uh cross country uh I heard
about that yeah I mean you guys can do
motivational towards with all that you
know the steroid talk and uh
but you know what was it the juice bar
and yeah
do you realize what's out there right
now it's it's not safe
truck stops are not safe anymore can he
stay at your house
which one
the one you're in now
uh what times he what time is he
traveling see what time would you be
passing through uh probably uh like
Thursday Friday ish
this Thursday Friday yeah next week next
next next Thursday Friday
oh next Thursday Friday well you know if
if we if we decide to head home I mean
he certainly could have the keys to the
house uh
we'd have to we'd have to I'd have to
I'd have to do a vetting check on him
how much then that's not good that's not
gonna happen
that's not gonna maybe he just goes to
the Montana house
did you go there it's cold yeah but it's
God it's beautiful and and I have some
friends up there that just started
jumping in the lake and you know oh my
God what they're crazy it's kind of a
challenge thing I have no idea I I I've
been challenged I don't want to be
challenged
like block you
or hit you like it
I'll tell you one time we were up there
in Montana
and this wasn't too long ago three four
years ago and uh Kyle was Kyle was up
there working out and he needed to work
on Kyle's 3 30 you know six seven
and heavy-handed really heavy-handed and
people who know heavy-handed understand
what I'm saying
I I was you know doing some simulated
moves on him you know jab in come out
you know he stuck me in the chest and
I'm telling you
I [ __ ] up
ah
is I I can't play with you anymore
you're I'm old you're not you're
my ribs were locked up for maybe
your kids are beating you up in your own
driveway
Anthony Munoz did that to me one time at
ESPN he came in and I would always do
like a swim move like I would I walk up
to him and I go hey Anthony and I do a
swim move and he saw it he laughed the
first couple of times and then I did it
one other time to him a couple of weeks
later he grabbed me with both hands in
the ribs and just held me there and
again you know what I you know what I
think is is really interesting I think
people think you know well I go to the
gym I'm I'm in good shape I you know I I
lift a lot of weight you know
football the NFL is like NASCAR I didn't
get NASCAR you you don't get NASCAR
watching TV you're just around and
around around okay enough already around
you go down turn three on the rail and a
car goes by at 200 miles an hour that's
the NFL and when you see something
six four two sixty runs of four four
it's a car going by and and that's the
other thing people always say well I run
a 4-7 or I run a four six or I run a
four or five
bologna you do uh it's a big league and
I say we need restrictor plates on our
league it's so big it's so fast uh these
defensive linemen the offensive lineman
hey look Terry Bradshaw's offensive line
average choose 55. yeah
the biggest line of football average is
325 right now the guy that plays Joe
Greene's position and Joe was 275 280 I
think that guy's 330.
I told people you would never let your
kids play football if you watched a game
from the sidelines an NFL game from the
sidelines and listen to the collisions
yes you would you would say oh I hope
they could play pop warner but that's
about it because it is no and that's
that's a great point until you're down
there on the field and you see the speed
and the impact you know you just don't
get it
um I certainly didn't say Diane and I
didn't certainly say wow we want our
kids to play football what's the exact
opposite on I don't think any of our
boys played as young kids uh Chris came
to me to say he wanted to play and Kyle
played baseball and uh tried to push him
towards baseball a little bit I think
but you know at the end of the day
genetics or genetics and you are who you
are
hey it's great to catch up with you hope
you you look great and uh you know Seton
is going to just keep driving by the
house he's not going to stop all right
next Thursday he will not head on to the
swivel Seaton head on a swift thank you
Hallie all right partner that's uh Howie
Long Hall of Famer always love having
him on Fox has the Niners and the Rams
that'll be Sunday at 6 30 Eastern